a six one seven eight three zero 4750 is
the number let's see who is calling in
from the 801 area code caller from 801
who's this hi David this is Carson
Hensley great go ahead hi I'm so
yesterday I saw one of your videos it
was yes
argument during that video that look ins
basically when they are I the odd you
know speak a little nervous but when
they they have different ideas of each
other used you brought up the point of
abortion and I was you're saying that
they still support each other even if
they disagree and my point is basically
why should we do what Republicans do
they stop why should we do what the
Republicans do because it seems that
because we want to win work because we
want to win i I don't you know this is
at a certain point it's like do we want
to just continue for the next 20 to 30
years keep losing power continue
allowing the judiciary the local levels
of elected officials municipalities
states allowing the supreme court to
become more and more conservative like
listen I from what I'm hearing in your
voice you're like me in that you are I
you're not an idealist of sorts you want
to achieve progress the way that feels
like the right way at a certain point
we've got to wake up and realize this is
what it is right now and at a certain
point if the left eats itself if you
start getting into these sort of tribal
battles you can have the moral high
ground and the right will continue to
win I personally don't want that I'm
against that I want to start winning
understand that where I'm coming from
that we have to vote for we might we
might win that we might win that
election but when progressive values we
lose our progressive values were trading
those and I disagree here's why let me
tell you why I disagree we have a system
right now between campaign finance
gerrymandering voter suppression right
all of the big media ownership and
consolidation we have a system that we
can't change unless we get more control
over the political system right so
whereas you might say if we play the
game we win a seat but we lose the
progressive values that were pushing for
we are not going to win on the values
unless we win a bunch of those seats now
where I agree with you is that there's a
risk that if you do too much of that
trading by the time you win a bunch of
seats the people that have won them
don't really care about the progressive
values right but that's where the voters
need to hold people accountable so I I
just think we're looking at this from an
idealism versus pragmatism point of view
I mean I somewhat agree I mean I think
that it's um it is a valid point to say
that yes we need to get more and more
Democrats in so that more and more
progressive Democrats are able to win
right it is stupid to say oh we should
just not go for the Democrats period
because I mean we do need to win and to
say that they're doing right now you
know not wanting to vote for a corporate
Democrat yeah all right well it sounds
like we mostly agree but maybe just
disagree on the details of the tactics
but this is an important issue and I'm
really really glad you brought it up
Carson thanks so much for the call
appreciate it I am out of time for call
sorry to everybody who called in but
didn't get through we will take calls
again and I really appreciate everybody
who called in